hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
let's play nightmare house - alright I
just get a challenge to get scared and I
only got a little scared just a little
bit alright moving on this flashlight
looks like an eyeball
I swear what do we got what do we got
Paul nothing MRI CT CT or MRI should
have a different uh CT CT scan CT strong
magnetic failed not stronger than me get
out of here
all right oh no this is a CT scanner I
think there are bolts et's I'm not sure
I I don't know my medical equipment in
there can't see a bloody thing um I'm
missing something
here can't go in there empty Wow all
right here
ah there we go gotcha I do something
with this I don't know what all right
okay
I'm gonna go in here oh I replace it
with this one okay ah fu get Oh what is
there knock-knock
get ready W at your face blown off ah
[ __ ] face blown up
done and done Oscar lenghten ah man I
bet I bet Billy's a ghost
Billy's a ghost he's in with the ghosts
or he is a ghost one of the two is there
oh oh hello
Oh both of you want to axe
I still smell you but should put on some
acts let me ask you a question what
rhymes with acts more acts all right I'm
out of acts puns
Oh Oh I got one more let me play you
some AXA phone Oh Oh sick burn good one
mark
don't turn around I'll turn around all I
want huh what really man else that's
weird
okay that did something oh the bride go
get it yeah oh yeah look
okay so that definitely is an MRI
oh well that mission accomplished let's
go home guys cuz whatever I set out to
do I did it I did it hardcore what did
that do
oh oh I see a little hole in the wall
damn
alright let's go oh this place are the
different what cold drinks oh don't get
up okay you don't have a head I'll
assume you're not gonna get up
so thirsty I really am in real life I'm
thirsty
hey what was that I saw that good good
out of here oh this is cool Oh Oh after
you bring it I'll bring it oh I'm gonna
get you
whoo kitchen boom I can't even fire boom
I'll go get you hum oh I'm gonna get you
I'll getcha I'll getcha oh yeah run away
huh alright no head no head put all your
heads go eyeball no no no one thought so
come on
oh yeah I win my throat oh oh yeah take
it away
yes I just use my axe oh yeah to these
things
I need to access because I can handle a
akimbo axe action Oh bring it yeah no no
yeah do the wave yeah that'll help you
oh let's see what you got oh nothing oh
yeah yeah nothing nothing can withstand
him my ox hey wait this is where I was I
went in a circle as I supposed to come
in here for something how do you hear
that
fuzzy sound that's his beat
all right no switch that guy was useless
maybe that door over here got open oh oh
everything got blue lose a calming color
ah you get away
oh we run down the walls hardly scary
not even a little bit oh that was freaky
oh that was really cool how they do that
Wow
and this this this mod is awesome honest
to god is like the coolest mod I've ever
seen
Oh what's this Oh bring it bring it on
I'm coming for you oh I'm coming for you
I'll bring it bring it
oh I'm so ready I'm so ready operat Oh
what is that was that like this citadel
in half-life 2 oh I've been blown out of
the field with the soul of regard at the
count of three was right okay waking up
again in some other place
thanks for closing the door behind you
parallel I been sleeping here awhile
Oh chair oh you guys messed up big time
you give me a chair Oh bring it oh I'll
bring it on never lose hope Hospital
does not allow patients and visitors
into its naming section uh-huh only
trained members of staff untrained staff
formations altering these areas grab the
risk of electrocution severe burns exits
the tension in LA
please turn away now have way yes Oh f
off you don't even know you're talking
to
it's even a way I can go if I wanted oh
I see it I see the solution blow it up
BAM boom come Louie oh yeah is so hard
what's that
what is that huh something that's about
ten die
bring it bring it up oh oh they're still
alive I thought you died or something or
something lost track of you for like 30
minutes
like what happened I'm like why your
back though look I know you can see her
she wants something from you I'll seize
your child isn't she be careful you're
you are her daddy
all this blocked my hobby it goes for
you but definitely her dad oh yeah go
back just a launching room if I'm right
about this there okay I'll trust you on
this one
third washing machine
hello hey God don't ya you've got up you
broke the rule now your face gets gone
oh man I don't like to do this but I
just got to take away your face this is
what happens yeah let me through there
thank you hi get away oh oh what's that
nothing get out of here close quarters
combat
all right
luta no one all right I got to cut it
here thank you guys so much for watching
and I will see you next time in let's
play nightmare house - bye bye
oh wow something all right bye-bye